I'm not your typical Carnegie Mellon
student like many of you my time here
feels short in my case I chose to spend
a semester abroad in India and graduate
a semester early but when I think of US
and I try to envision a typical CMU
student it's difficult there's something
about the word typical that makes me
stumble because really who is a typical
CMU student someone who's double
majoring in math and computer science
minoring in physics and looks like he
never sleeps or a multilingual
mountain-climbing artist who wants to
start her own kinetic sculpture gallery
abroad or in New Jersey and mechanical
engineer who plays in the kiltie band is
a varsity diver and still has time to
found a new fraternity I could go on and
on listing more and more examples of the
remarkable accomplishments aspirations
and attitudes of the undergraduate and
graduate students but of course there is
no typical CMU student sitting before me
is a graduating class that it's
constantly redefining typical and
redefining normal or rather we defy the
word typical we defy normal a week into
my semester abroad I was in a small
bookstore in Kerala South India with a
group of Americans I circled the aisles
of the bookstore looking for something
hefty to get me through the next few
weeks then I turned a corner and saw it
the last lecture exactly the same as the
beautiful hardbound copy that the class
of 2012 received in the mail nearly four
years ago but all of the text was in
Malayalam a curled indecipherable script
even so I was ecstatic to find this
piece of home so far from where I'd
first encountered it I tried to explain
to my friend Lea
about the significance of the book Randy
Pausch is legacy in the glowing bridge
but I became distracted transported back
to Pittsburgh back to orientation week
to discussion with other eat our
residents about climbing over brick
walls back to convocation the August
humidity and Jeffries as low speech it
seems like this was yesterday doesn't it
Leah nudged me back to reality asking
about Carnegie Mellon how had my
experience been so far what were the
people like these were difficult
questions to answer in a sentence or two
people are kind of atypical I said every
single person I've met is really
passionate about something incredibly
specific they throw themselves into
whatever they do using whatever means
necessary
Leah nodded and I thought of a few of
the amazing people I knew back at school
a friend who launched a crowd-sourced
education project another who led a
student movement and sex trafficking in
Pittsburgh and yet another who's
building an outdoor learning studio for
preschoolers I tried to explain even the
world's biggest problems don't scare us
we that's all of us our critical
thinkers builders debaters artists
travelers and storytellers we may stay
in Pittsburgh or you may move hundreds
even thousands of miles away taking what
we learned here to make the world a
little better than how we found it we
will try to solve everything from your
books cubes to world hunger
we will try in unconventional ways with
very little sleep in another language on
a computer or in the lab relying on
friends or doing it completely on our
own we all know this perseverance I'm
talking about and this makes me really
proud of us but regardless of how we go
about tackling the world's problems we
will all have one thing in common we
will defy normal even more than defying
normal Carnegie Mellon
it's defy explanation we defy examples
and lists we defy archetypal
twenty-somethings at a prestigious
university we defy the places we are
from the majors and minors and
certificates we pursue the jobs people
think we will have sure we use our
majors and minors and interests and
origins to explain ourselves but we are
more than this we defy these
explanations because Carnegie Mellon is
a place for innovation creativity
passion resourcefulness and hard work we
might come in with some of these things
but the university community the faculty
the staff and our peers shape our
experience professor's become friends
inviting us to dinner in their homes
friends become mentors running stucco's
those are student talk courses for
credit on everything from how to get a
job to improv comedy and our mentors
become our closest allies helping us to
build whatever we can dream up cheering
us on and letting us learn from our
failures and successes this place may
seem impossibly weird sometimes full of
quirky traditions like painting the
fence and bagpiping on special and not
so special occasions but that's of
course what is so distinct about this
place many of us will call home now I
missed CMU before I even left and though
we will all scatter far and wide after
today I know we will see each other
again the world is smaller than we know
and our community as well as our impact
is greater than we can imagine
so here's what I hope for you when you
are alone in the world and you see a
tartan sticker on a car 3,000 miles from
Pittsburgh or when you run across a copy
of the last lecture translated into a
language you don't
no remember your time here and remember
all the Carnegie Mellon graduates out
there defying typical defying normal and
most of all feel encouraged continue to
defy explanation and expectations just
as we did on this campus and in these
buildings congratulations the most
atypical group of people I have ever had
the pleasure of knowing